[Music]
we're gonna go to 29 rooms of Instagram
heaven Instagram is pretty much my job
so if you haven't seen his face before
you probably definitely seen his
Instagram she shoots really really
really cool Letta CLE please photos my
relationship with Instagram I love it I
don't think it loves me you know I
haven't seen your profile you can check
it out these are good but I can I can
definitely help you out let's do it we
made it to 29 rooms is a pop-up here in
Williamsburg New York and it's a huge
fun house of 29 different aesthetically
pleasing rooms that were made to be put
on your Instagram I really like the
disco ball room I wouldn't like stay
away from that do you wanna do you want
to put on sunglasses we're doing some
yellow by
see they're all like so different so
freaking cool see the glass we were kind
of distracted by taking pictures the
whole time but we didn't realize that
[Music]
each room had a different deeper meaning
we've covered it throughout like I mean
dick oh that's cool let's go looking at
this is again
Brandon's aesthetic what is this that
projection right there is me what made
me into art I loved how like every room
was created by different artists you
mean that's in the gardens and we got to
learn like a little bit of their
backstories I was the artist the room is
called the Beatrice female is in
collaboration with mom
lyrics from her song and decorated all
these punching bags with them and then
also added seven servicing of bag
[Music]
oh my god I feel so powerful he's a
really good way to you
we just walked in this giant tent called
the womb we are in the world these
headphones are like a heartbeat and I
feel like an actual baby the thing we
come out one of my favorite ones was
called shred it and it's basically
writing down what ever is weighing you
down in life I hope people I was like
looking kidding and putting it through
the shredder was like a cool releasing
spoon release whatever you're stressing
up tweening room there's a lot more than
just a simple Instagram it was a totally
different experience as for us well I
did step up my Instagram game and
Brandon took some bomb-ass photos of me
we were just having fun enjoying it all
I'm so it was a nice way to appreciate
art and experience it
Instagram heaven ready not on a twenty
nine would recommend do you guys say
like thanks for watching thanks for
watching like no yeah we just ended by
wow I don't think it could breathe this
would be a good room right where's your
phone
[Music]